- Hi, everyone.
I'm Saad Omer.
I'm the director of the Yale
Institute for Global Health.
I'm really delighted to welcome you
to the "Global Health Conversation" series
in addition to the Yale Institute
for Global Health, or YIGH.
The series is co-sponsored
by the Walker Fund
at the MacMillan Center at Yale.
Well, a lot of you probably know
that the eradication of disease
is defined as a deliberate set of efforts
towards a permanent reduction to zero
of the worldwide incidence of infection
caused by a specific agent.
The eradication efforts require
enormous planning and effort
and implementation, and dedication.
The eradication of smallpox,
the only human disease that
has been eradicated so far,
was spearheaded by the
Smallpox Eradication Program,
launched by the World
Health Organization in 1976.
This multiprong initiative
focused on endemic countries,
and utilized a combination
of surveillance,
case finding, contact
tracing, ring vaccination,
and communication campaigns,
to inform affected population.
Fueled by worldwide support by 1973,
the number of countries where the smallpox
had substantially decreased,
with the last infection
reported in Somalia
on October 26th, 1977.
So WHO teams searched for
possible smallpox infections
in the next couple of years,
finding no further cases.
And at the 33rd World
Health Assembly in 1980,
so approximately 42 years ago,
smallpox was officially deemed eradicated.
To reflect this momentous effort
and discuss eradication in the context
of the present and the future,
I'm so pleased to have
with us, Dr. William Foege,
or Dr. Bill Foege, the former Chief
for Smallpox Eradication Program,
and a former Director of the
CDC between 1977 and 1983.
In his leadership role within
the Smallpox Eradication Program,
Dr. Foege pioneered the technique known as
the "Surveillance Containment,"
developed a combat,
spread of smallpox in the
face of vaccine shortages.
So it was--
Public health is about
life giving you lemons
and making lemonade, that
was one useful lemonade
that helped us eradicate.
And this was a combination of
both theoretical understanding
of what was going on, but
also applied public health.
And I remain as an infectious
disease epidemiologist,,
I remain a fan of that approach
that was very suitable for that disease.
And so using this method,
Dr. Foege and his team
was able to play a major
role in eradicating
an infectious disease for the
first time in human history.
Subsequently, and that was just--
I think it's reasonable to say now,
because we know the rest of the story,
that was the start of
his career, if you will,
if you look at the full trajectory.
He then went on to be a
legendary CDC director in 77',
where he served for six years.
He co-founded the Task
Force for Child Survival
and Development,
now known as "Task Force
for Global Health,"
played a major role in the development
and evolution of the Carter Center,
provided invaluable
advice at the beginning
and the foundation of
the Gates Foundation,
and so on and so forth.
He remains a Professor Emeritus at Emory.
And personally speaking,
one of the proudest things in
my career, for me personally,
was to be the second ever
Bill Foege professor at Emory.
And so that was an incredible honor.
And as an aside, when
I would teach my class,
and Dr. Foege would lecture
in that on smallpox,
first of all, what I
get for a vaccine class,
we would have--
He would be the only lecturer
who would have his own fan base in class,
and there would be a
line for people taking,
initially all school photos,
but increasingly selfies with him,
and getting his book signed,
copies of his book signed.
One of the most remarkable
thing about Bill Foege
is that he's not only
a scientist, but he is,
if I could say so, the original
social justice warriors,
in the sense, focusing on
equity as part of the core DNA
of public health and global health.
Before, we had labels around these issues.
And so it is my pleasure
and honor to talk to him
about smallpox eradication,
but also having a forward
looking discussion
of what are the implications
on future eradication efforts,
future global health and
public health efforts,
and what are some of the lessons
us mere mortals can learn
from giants like Dr. Foege.
So welcome Dr. Foege.
- Thanks, Saad.
Thanks for having me.
Thanks for being a professor at Emory.
Thanks for bringing
some glitter to my name.
And it's good to be on this program.
- My pleasure.
So the first question is simple,
is the eradication worth it?
- Let me divide that into two things,
one has to do with people
and the other with money.
For people, think of
the fact that WHO said
in the 20th century, 300
million people died of smallpox.
Since most all of them
died in the first 75 years,
that means there were 4
million deaths a year.
And that is about as high as any disease.
I mean, tuberculosis and
measles were in that category,
but 4 million deaths a year plus
4 million people scarred for life.
And so from the personal
point of view, it's worth it.
Then you look at the money,
and it's said that it cost
about $300 million to eradicate smallpox,
half of this came from the United States.
Well, the United States
has recouped its investment
every three months because
of what it used to cost
to treat people who had complications
because of the vaccine, who died,
or the fact that we
had to have quarantine.
So since smallpox has been eradicated,
we have recouped our investment 130 times,
every dollar that was invested
has come back with $130.
So yes, it's worth it.
In many ways, we borrow from our children.
And when you look at climate
change and what we've done
to the plastic in the ocean and so forth,
we're depending on our
children and grandchildren
to pay that off.
Well, disease eradication is
one way that we pay forward,
and we actually give a
gift to our grandchildren.
So yes, it's worth it.
- Wonderful.
So, we know, and then those of us
who have read your writings about it,
so small blocks eradication
ran into roadblocks
and had areas of efficiency.
So how many of those
roadblocks or positive aspects
are applicable in the current day?
Are there any new difficulties
or new challenges,
or areas that have improved
since smallpox was eradicated?
- I think every day during the
Smallpox Eradication Program
was a problem-solving day.
And we looked for people that had a record
of being problem solvers.
So in 2020, we expected to
have a meeting in Atlanta
to celebrate 40 years
since the WHO declaration.
And as part of that, we were looking at,
what are the positive lessons
that we learned from smallpox?
Then the pandemic came along,
we could not have that meeting.
So instead, we continued to work on,
what are the lessons learned,
and could we put them into a curriculum
which we've done under the umbrella
of becoming better ancestors
that would actually
have something to say
for today and tomorrow?
So it so happened that we
were looking at these lessons
during the coronavirus pandemic,
and I'm just gonna go
through the nine lessons
we focused on very quickly,
to show you the difference
between smallpox and coronavirus.
Number one lesson is, this
is a cause and effect world.
And Sphene Hawking says this in his book,
"A Short History of Time,"
that the whole history of science
is the gradual realization
that things do not happen
in an arbitrary way, it's
a cause and effect world.
And so on coronavirus, we have a president
that says it's gonna disappear like magic.
Then a second lesson is,
you have to know the truth.
And there were times when we
did not want to know the truth.
And I remember October of 1973,
our first village to
village search in India,
and in just two states,
we found 10,000 new cases of smallpox
that no one knew existed
in just six days time.
And some people said,
"Let's never do this again."
But of course you have to do it again,
it's the best surveillance
you've ever had.
So there are many times
you don't want the truth,
but you need the truth
in order to continue.
But a third lesson is, you
don't do anything alone,
it requires coalitions.
So in this country, we should
have had, for coronavirus,
a coalition that went from
national level that said,
"Here are some guidelines,
and you can change these
in states and cities and
counties as you need to."
But instead, our government
said to the state,
"You're all on your own to compete.
Figure out this on your own
and compete for resources."
The next lesson that we
learned was, avoid certainty.
And Richard Feynman, the physicist said,
"Physics is the most certain of sciences,
and it's uncertain."
And he said, "Certainty is the
Achilles' heel of science."
And of course, it is of
politics and religion,
and everything else.
But we had so much certainty
given by various people
at press conferences on coronavirus.
The fifth lesson, you have
to continuously evaluate
and change what you're doing.
In India, this meant we
had a meeting every month
in endemic states to find
out what worked last month,
what didn't work,
how do we change our
tactics the next month?
And in this country with coronavirus,
we didn't have that kind of evaluation
and changing of what was happening.
A sixth lesson, respect the culture.
And we know that if you
go in with your ideas
of how to do things,
culture will always win.
So if you tangle with
culture, cultural will win,
you have to respect it from the beginning.
The next lesson was, the trade-off between
science and management, the best decisions
come from the best science,
the best results come
from the best management.
So how do you put science
and management together?
The eighth lesson, you
need political support.
And this just becomes absolutely essential
that you have politics involved.
And many people have
concluded after coronavirus,
"We don't want politicians
involved in public health."
That's absolutely the wrong conclusion,
that it's the politicians that decide
on the money that we get.
We need them to help solve the problems,
become part of the solution,
to be invested in the solution,
rather than saying we wanna
separate ourselves from them.
And the last lesson is,
no matter where you live,
you're both global and local.
And so wherever you're
practicing public health,
you're practicing global public health.
And the objective of global public health
is global health equity.
So everyone in public health is working
on global health equity.
Well, no one in public
health even imagined
in the midst of a pandemic
that we would leave WHO.
So all of this is to show how the lessons
that we learned from
smallpox were ignored.
Which leads to the 10th and last lesson,
lessons are useless if ignored.
- Now that's very insightful.
And a couple of things
specifically strike me.
You have to engage our elected leaders,
especially in democracies
and even otherwise,
but it doesn't have to be partisan.
So political doesn't have to be partisan.
And you've shown, you
and several other leaders
have been well respected
on both sides of the aisle,
and have been able to make
the case for public health,
which is obviously harder
because as you have often said,
public health is effective
and nothing happens.
And so therefore, it is challenging,
but I think it's doable.
So switching gears a little bit,
CDC has identified the
virus that causes smallpox
as a potential bioterrorism threat.
In a changing world
where biological capacity
is increasingly available
beyond a few specialized labs,
and there are perverse incentives
for state and non-state actors to engage
in activities that are
not necessarily ethical,
how do we reduce and mitigate
or even eliminate the risk?
- I think bioterrorism with smallpox virus
has been a concern right
from the beginning.
And particularly, before the
United States invaded Iraq,
and there were questions about,
did Iraq have the virus,
and were they using it for
research on bioterrorism?
And in fact, there was a story,
front page of the New York Times,
saying they did have the virus
that had been provided to them by Russia.
And that it was a virus that
you could not protect against
with our current vaccine.
Well, the administration
came up with a plan
to first vaccinate first responders,
then they would go to
10 million beyond that.
And then the question was,
would they go to the
whole population or not?
The Institute of Medicine was
asked to oversee that program.
And I was asked to be a member of it,
but I was told that we
could not produce a report
that criticized the administration.
I was taken back by that.
And I said, "Well, I
can't be part of it then."
Later they came and they asked
if I would be a consultant
if I was not able to vote or anything,
and then I could say anything I wanted.
And so I did do an op-ed
piece for the Washington Post,
and pointed out, if it's
true that they have a virus
that you cannot protect
against with vaccine,
why are we spending so much attention
on vaccination in this country?
And number two, why don't we
realize that if there's a case,
the problem in the United
States will be panic.
It won't be the disease
itself, it'll be the panic.
And the plan was that they
could get to 10 million people
in 10 days of vaccination.
I said, if there were cases,
we would have 300 million people
trying to get in that line of 10 million,
and it's the panic that
would cause the problem.
I proposed a solution to CDC
and they didn't accept it.
And so I simply put it
as a one page summary
in my book on, "House on
Fire," which is very simple,
that you look at the 3000 counties
as the point at which we
would respond to smallpox.
We would in each county
use the high schools
as the point of vaccination.
It's very easy to estimate
how many people live
in the catchment area of a high school.
If you could tell the
entire country, if need be,
we could vaccinate everyone
in three days time,
and that would prevent the
next cases of smallpox,
you could prevent the panic.
You can train people in 10 minutes
to do vaccination with
a bifurcated needle.
So we would know how many
vaccinators we would need,
and we would get nurses,
we would get teachers,
we could volunteers and retired people.
So you could line all
of this up in advance,
you could keep the vaccine
at a national level
and send it out overnight to
3000 counties, if you had to.
And once you can assure the country,
everyone could be vaccinated
in three days time,
you take away the panic factor.
Now, it's relatively easy
to do that with smallpox,
it's much more complicated
to do this with other agents.
But we weren't even able to come up
with a reasonable response to smallpox,
so you can see the difficulties
of a response to other problems.
- No, that's an interesting
point that you highlighted,
that things vary by pathogen,
but also that there are things
that you can do even about panic.
And sometimes we are paralyzed
by the potential fear of public reaction,
where we often forget the basic principles
of public health and public
health communication.
Well, in every other
School of Public Health,
or in every School of Public Health,
there is a discussion in every semester
about the value of vertical
versus horizontal programs.
You led one of the most vertical programs
and then have worked on enhancing
some of the most horizontal
programs, et cetera.
So what are the implications
of vertical disease specific programs
versus horizontal programs
and their impact on primary healthcare?
- So you can put vertical
versus horizontal
on any program and get
people gathering in a room
because there are strong
feelings on both sides.
And I came to a conclusion in the 1980s
when I was President of the American
Public Health Association for a year
and had to give the keynote address.
And so I decided to go back 100 years
to see what they were discussing
100 years earlier at APHA.
And to my total surprise,
I found that the discussion
was vertical versus horizontal.
I thought that that was a fairly
recent global health discussion,
and here it went back 100 years.
So I said to myself,
"Well, in 100 years, what
happened in this country?"
And it was very clear, every
time we had a tool, we used it,
which is vertical.
And every time we used it, we
improved the infrastructure,
which was horizontal.
And that made it easier
to take the next tool
and include it.
So it was always a ratcheting
up, a vertical, horizontal,
vertical, horizontal.
And so there should be no
discussion of which is best,
they're both needed.
And so, we have to actually educate people
in how to make that happen
so that this doesn't become the argument.
- Yeah, no, you're right.
And then sometimes it's
presented as a false choice.
So switching gears a little bit again,
and what have been some
salient, for lack of word,
failures and successes, and triumphs
in the COVID 19 pandemic?
- It really was a triumphant tragedy.
The tragedy I've just pointed out,
was the nine lessons that were ignored.
The triumph is, look at
what happened with vaccines,
I went back in my journal
and found that the first note
I ever made on messenger
RNA was 25 years ago
after hearing a lecture.
And I wondered what
would happen after that.
So you see how long people
have been working on that.
For much of the public,
they think that the work was
just in the last year or two,
or three, and here it's
been going on all the time.
This was the triumph of coronavirus,
a vaccine that came online so fast,
where you had government support.
And the other part of this triumph is,
we have for the last 30 years,
averaged about one new
disease problem a year.
Each time we get excited
about it, we get funds,
and we think this is
finally going to change
the infrastructure of public health.
And we are soon going to reach
the same level as fire stations.
That is, if a fire station in an airport
doesn't have a disaster for 10 years,
no one wants to reduce their budget.
Everyone understands you
have to keep funding it.
So we always think,
that's what's gonna happen
in public health, we'll get an
infrastructure that is solid
and continues on, and it never happens.
I thought with coronavirus,
for sure this is going to happen.
I no longer believe that
that's going to happen.
And we have to figure out how
to make that actually happen
so that it's part of the
triumph of coronavirus.
- Yeah. So in terms of the premier
Public Health Agency in
this country, the CDC,
what should the CDC look like
after this pandemic is under control?
Or while obviously, it will take some time
to bring the pandemic fully
under control, we can start now.
So what should be the feature of the CDC?
- There are three or four
things Saad, that I think of,
you notice that the field of public health
has continued to increase.
It was pretty much infectious
diseases when I started it,
and became interested
in this 70 years ago,
but it's then gone from
occupational health
to environmental health,
to chronic diseases,
to violence and injury,
it keeps increasing.
We still have a couple of
areas that should be included,
mental health is one of them.
It's been very hard to make
this a public health issue,
but it has to be, because we have to have
surveillance systems for mental health,
that we know who requires
treatment and how to proceed.
The other thing is, I think public health
should be taking a lead
on actually looking
on health outcomes by the
approach with clinical medicine.
In this country, we are satisfied
to reward people on the basis of process.
So how many tests are
done for this or that,
and how many pap smears and so forth,
rather than on outcome.
And it always surprises
people to know we spend
twice as much per capita
as any place else,
and yet we're not in the
top five or 10, or 15, or 20
countries when it comes
to health outcomes.
So that's one problem.
Number two, I think we
simply have to re-look at,
what's the science, the
technology, the skills
that are needed at CDC to
keep it at the cutting edge
of public health.
They've taken a step by
having a person from HHS,
now take a month to look at CDC
and come up with suggestions.
But we all know that things have become
so political in this country
that half the country
will not accept what comes
from inside HHS to CDC.
And I think we need an outside group
looking at the things I just
mentioned, of technology,
skills and so forth.
And I would like to see the
National Academy of Medicine
do such a study.
Number three, I think that CDC
should have a series of
conferences with states,
counties, cities, tribes,
and ask the question,
how do we get the approach to
public health in this country
as seamless as it was 40 years ago?
Because 40 years ago we had--
CDC had no more authority,
they could not go in to a state
and investigate an (mumbles) cum-problem.
And they could not decide on
who would do what in the state.
They always had to ask for
an invitation, but it worked.
And why did it work?
Because there was trust,
and trust is the glue
that keeps a coalition together.
So we can get back to that,
but it's gonna require
a series of meetings
with all of the people involved.
It's a different time.
When I was in the Health
Department in Colorado,
the Health Director in Colorado
had been there 30 years,
that doesn't happen anymore.
People are there for two
years and they change
as soon as the governor changes.
It is the same thing at CDC.
I was CDC director under
both Carter and Reagan,
you can't see that happening again.
But that's the next
thing that CDC has to do,
is figure out how to make a
seamless approach to this.
And the last thing, I think
they need to get some outside
consultation on communications.
How would it be best for health
workers around the country?
For instance, CDC puts out
the Morbidity, Mortality
Weekly Report each week,
they could send this to all
health officers the night before
with a brief on, what
are the complications
to expect the next day?
So everybody's looking
at the same material.
So there are things that could
be done to improve and help
CDC at this time.
It's critical that we have a CDC.
- Yeah, no, the CDC is
essential for this country
and globally, because of
its global role as well.
So you alluded to trust
in the Centers for Disease
Control and Prevention,
and you alluded to trust
between institutions,
between the CDC and the states, et cetera.
But there's a broader, unfortunate problem
of public trust in CDC,
and it has been measured,
and it has declined.
There was another period
where the trust in CDC
was dented a bit, which was around
the Swine Flu Vaccine Program in 1976,
where there was this alarm
for a potential pandemic
or a large outbreak, there was
a vaccine program rolled out,
there were some adverse events associated
with the vaccine program,
with a vaccine related
to G-barre Syndrome,
which turned out to be
true but not at a level
where perhaps it changed
the risk, benefit risk.
But there was some
lessons for communications
and policy, et cetera.
And I'm describing it,
not for you, obviously,
you know this by heart,
I'm just setting the stage for those of us
who were doing other things at that time,
like being in kindergarten.
(William laughing)
So I'm not that young,
but our audience is.
But going back to that
period in that context,
but also beyond that,
any lessons on restoring
public trust in the CDC?
- Well, you're right to point out my age,
because I was actually involved in that.
And I attended the--
Dave Sencer was the director of CDC,
and I attended the very
first PD he ever had on this,
with the Advisory Committee
on Immunization Practices.
It was an emergency meeting on a Saturday.
And what was presented was,
three things have happened,
we have a new virus.
Number two, we have evidence
of human-to-human spread
Fort Dix, New Jersey.
And number three, there is no
immunity in the population.
Those three things had
never happened before
without resulting in a pandemic.
And so it wasn't difficult
for the group to say,
"There's gonna be a pandemic."
The discussion though, revolved around,
we have to make vaccine,
do we store the vaccine in refrigerators,
or do we store it in people?
Well, if you store it in refrigerators,
we know from experience,
that a flu outbreak
can go across this
country in two weeks time.
If you vaccinate someone with a vaccine,
it may take two weeks
for them to get immunity.
So there's really no
way that you can justify
waiting until you have spread of the virus
before you start vaccinating.
That's why there was a
decision on vaccinating.
It was not a decision made in isolation.
Sencer did not even take a
vote of the committee that day.
And I asked him
afterwards, why didn't you?
And he said, "Because this is
gonna be a political problem."
And he said, "I need to absorb it
rather than have the committee absorb it."
But it went all the
way to the Oval Office.
And in the Oval Office
with President Ford,
with Sencer presenting what we knew,
they had in the group, Salk, and Sabin,
and some of the best
virologists of the day,
and they all told Ford,
"This was the thing to do."
Then as soon as we ran
into the first cases
of Guillain-Barre, suddenly
people started jumping ship.
And eventually, it was only Dave Sencer
who was being blamed
for what had happened.
The program was stopped
because of Guillain-Barre,
and Sencer was fired by Joseph Califano,
actually not by Califano,
but by his deputy.
And so that's how difficult
the political situation
was at that time.
But CDC did not lose its credibility.
And therefore, even though
there was some reduction
in the glue of trust,
it all came back again.
And particularly with
Legionnaire's disease
and the solving of that
problem, the trust came back.
At the present time, the trust
factor is really important,
because I see public health
people not trusting each other,
I see the public not
trusting public health.
And 30 years ago, I gave a talk at CDC,
and I was talking about
how there are people who,
like Gandhi, did the right things,
but we don't know about them in history.
But I said, "There are also institutions
that become Gandhian institutions,
and that CDC was one of them."
But that reputation doesn't
go on into the future,
it has to be earned every day.
And that's the challenge of CDC right now,
is to earn that reputation back every day.
And I think it can be done.
- Interesting. So now,
I'm taking some questions
from the audience and those
of you who are listening in,
please feel free to add your questions.
So I already have a few questions.
And the first one is,
will you please compare
the eradication of smallpox
to the effort to eradicate
the Guinea worm disease,
which has been described, et cetera,
including in the book by Don
Hopkins and Ernesto Ruiz-Tiben.
I know that you have been
engaged with both individuals
and institutions like the Carter Center,
who have been at the
forefront of the program.
So any lessons that translated,
and any lessons that did
not translate or transfer
between the Smallpox Program
and the Guinea Worm Disease Program?
- First, I think all nine
lessons do in fact transfer.
But Guinea worm had some
problems and barriers
that smallpox didn't.
With smallpox, it was very
hard to keep cases hidden,
because the disease was
on the face and the hands.
And so people deliberately
would hide cases,
but it was hard, difficult.
With Guinea worm, the
disease wasn't even known
in the capital cities,
it wasn't even known
where you had the Health Department.
And I think Nigeria turns out
to be a good example of that,
that they were reporting
5,000 or 6,000 cases
of Guinea worm a year.
Well, that didn't seem
like a very big problem.
But there was a one-time
survey done in Nigeria
that showed, at one point in time,
almost 700,000 cases of Guinea worm.
And for those 700,000 people,
it was hard to go to school,
it was hard to work in the field.
I mean, this really did
cause a change in lifestyle,
but Ministry of Health
didn't know about this.
But with that survey in Nigeria,
the president of Nigeria,
President Yakubu Gowon was so
surprised by that result.
He put up a million dollars
in Nigerian money that day
for Guinea worm eradication.
So it shows the need
for political support,
and how do you get that
kind of political support.
They've also run into a problem of course,
with animals and particularly dogs
that transmit Guinea worm.
We knew from the beginning
that there was Guinea worm
reported in some animals,
but it was always--
It looked like a dead end,
not something that went to humans.
And now in Chad, there's
some certain places
where a lot of dogs have Guinea worm.
I think that this problem
is going to be solved,
there were only 15 cases of
human Guinea worm last year
in the entire world, 15,
compare that to the millions
that we used to have.
But here's the problem, that
we have to evolve faster
than the organism does.
In smallpox, that was always clear to me,
that the approach from the
smallpox virus point of view,
and work for centuries.
And now we were evolving
faster than the virus,
and the virus couldn't keep up.
We have to do the same
thing with Guinea worm.
- Yeah. So you alluded to
animal reservoirs, et cetera.
And then when you do
these tabletop exercises
and diseases are evaluated
potential for eradication,
and a big no, no, not an absolute no, no,
but a big no, no, is a
existence of a human--
A non-human, sorry, reservoir.
But look, we have been making
investments in one health,
we are better at measuring infection
and pathogens in animals,
as well as humans.
Do you think it's time to be
a little bit more audacious?
Is there room for audacity,
to say that this criteria is much softer,
or should be softer than
has been traditionally?
And can we be bold enough
to look at diseases
that have animal reservoirs
for potential elimination or eradication?
- Absolutely. when you look
at the last 30 diseases
that have come unexpectedly
to our attention,
75% of them involve an animal or a vector,
and yet we do not do animal
and human surveillance together
at CDC or WHO until
there's a specific problem,
and then we do ad hoc animal surveillance.
So we really have to figure out how to get
the one world approach on surveillance.
I haven't looked at this for some years,
but I think there's only
one place in the world
that actually has what we used to call,
a "Class 4 lab for animals,"
and a "Class 4 lab for
humans" in the same city.
And that's Winnipeg, Canada.
And it was by accident, two
people that were interested,
it wasn't part of a big plan.
So we haven't approached this as a unit
in the past and we have to from now on.
- Yeah. So a couple of questions from--
Additional questions,
a few other questions
from the audience.
And one I think, is
from a former CDC person
if I recognize the name correctly.
And they ask, when will the CDC have
a long term Emergency Response Division,
a fixed team of professionals
who are assigned to ERD full-time?
Obviously there is some capacity
in some organizational
structures that are activated,
that are semi-permanent, but
I think they're talking about
something more permanent, more focused,
and with dedicated resources.
- Interesting thing here Saad,
is we had that in the early 1980s,
and people don't know that.
But we had a program at CDC
where we looked at each
organism and asked the question,
what would we do if we were
trying to use this offensively?
And therefore, what do we need to do
to come up with a defense?
This was with CDC and the
FBI, with secure phones,
secure rooms, and 24
hour a day people on call
in order to be able to look
at a particular problem.
I was so pleased what
was happening with this?
When I left, this was
presented to the new director,
and his response was, "Oh,
this will never happen."
And he closed on the program overnight.
So this was in CDCs history,
and it has to now be in CDCs future.
- So the next question,
I'm actually combining
a couple of questions there.
And one of the question is,
one of our living legends,
Jerry Friedland here at TL, who did some-
Has been doing, and has
did some pioneering work
in the early parts and subsequent
parts of the HIV epidemic.
I'm combining a couple of questions there.
So could you please
comment on the ongoing,
concurrent global pandemics of TB and HIV
in the context of the
rapid COVID 19 pandemic,
and what lessons can be
learned, and especially,
and the related part is that in terms
of the role of the CDC,
you had just left the CDC
when HIV came to fore,
in terms of an epidemic,
and then eventually became a pandemic.
So any thoughts on HIV
AIDS from the early days,
and the response to that,
and then what are the implications
of COVID 19 and the current situation
on these global pandemics
of TB and HIV AIDS?
- Well, as you know Saad,
I'm not smart enough to
answer these questions.
But I will give you a
top of the head feeling.
With HIV, it took quite
some time, didn't it,
before people saw this
as a global problem.
I remember those days in
Africa with medical people,
teachers, missionaries were dying faster
than they could be replaced,
and you just had no idea
where this was going to go.
And it had to be seen as a global problem
before we could get global solutions.
Will Durant used to say
that we will never do things
on a global level unless
we fear an alien invasion.
And it struck me one day
that we have surrogates
for an alien invasion,
and HIV eventually became
one of those surrogates
for alien invasion.
And so I think, one of the great things
that George W. Bush did,
was to put huge amounts of money
into a global approach to HIV,
and we've gotta credit
him for having done that,
But we should be very
careful in public health
to do other things as surrogates
for an alien invasion.
It's what probably led
to smallpox eradication,
because everyone knew
smallpox was a threat,
even if they hadn't seen it for a while.
In this country, we had
not had a case since 1949,
and yet the US participated
because they saw this
as a threat to the US, not
just to other countries.
And so that's part of what we
need to do in public health,
is to show how things
are a threat globally,
and how they become a surrogate
for an alien invasion.
Coronavirus, it hurts a lot
to see how we did not respond globally
the way we should have.
The Gavi actually had an
approach to the global program
where they had a lot of buy-in,
but they couldn't get
the vaccine at first.
And much of the enthusiasm
then started disappearing.
But we have to again,
say every place we are
is both local and global,
and that our job is global health equity.
- Yeah. And so coming to another question.
So why are the public
health systems in the US
so fragmented?
There are obviously states,
county and federal levels,
but there are different
policies in different states,
obviously part of it is a feature
of the system of
governance in this country.
Because constitutionally, the
police powers of the states
which include quarantine powers
and all sorts of other stuff
resides within the states,
not at the federal government level,
although there's some
limited exercise of that,
but we could align them better.
We managed with the same constitutional
and legal infrastructure, we
managed to have, for example,
a working Intrastate Highway System,
public health remains fragmented.
And so any thoughts on that?
- And as I mentioned before,
we did not need more authority
because we had so many people
from CDC who were actually
working in states.
We had so many state people who had taken
part of their training at CDC,
that this trust factor was
different at that time.
It's become politicized since then,
because every state governor
has their own health advisor
now, and they switch a lot.
But I think we can get back
to that by figuring out,
what is required to make this seamless?
What do states need from
the federal government
to make this happen?
And so I haven't given up on the idea
that we don't need more
authority. We need more trust.
- And perhaps more money. And if I can--
One thing I have heard
you say a few times,
heard you quote Dolly Parton a few times,
that it takes money to look this cheap,
if I'm paraphrasing that correctly.
- She said, "You'd be surprised
how much it costs to look this cheap."
- Yeah, you said it right.
And we don't invest enough,
there are high returns on
investment on public health,
and we still don't take as
a country, and as a world,
don't take the rational
decision of investing
in public health.
So in terms of--
We talked about bioterrorism et cetera,
and there's a direct
question from the audience,
which says, should the smallpox variants
in the two labs in Atlanta
and Moscow be destroyed.
And I would say that that's
a naive assumption if I may,
that it is only in two
labs, there are undeclared,
but confirmed reserves, correct me
if my interpretation is incorrect,
but still it's limited places
where the virus exists.
Do you think it's too big a threat
to have the virus even
present in those two places,
or other places as well?
- So one has to look
at, what is the threat
if we would unilaterally
destroy smallpox virus
in this country?
And the vaccine is not made from a virus,
so we don't need the virus
in order to make vaccine,
a vaccine is a different virus.
It's hard to see any
advantage to keeping the virus
because we now have the genetic code
of every strain of smallpox virus.
And we know that it's probably
possible to recreate this
if someone wanted to,
I see no advantage for keeping
the virus in either place.
And I see no advantage to
keeping it in this country
if Russia refuses to destroy theirs.
So I would say, we
should destroy our virus
because I can't see any
advantage to having it.
- Okay. So there's another question.
And I'll take the liberty of
modifying it a little bit.
How do you see the role of WHO
in conjunction with CDC,
but also as an entity
that needs to evolve with
the public health threats?
How do you see the role
of WHO going forward?
- I always tell people, WHO
is absolutely essential,
if we didn't have it,
we'd have to create it.
And so the real question
is, how do we improve it?
And unfortunately, the United States
was involved in making
it as weak as it is,
because when it was created,
we insisted on strong regional offices
because we were trying to protect PAHO.
And so the regional
offices are strong enough,
they can undermine Geneva
any time they want to.
And apparently they often want to.
And so with Ebola in
2016, the first big fight
was between WHO Geneva and
WHO Afro on who's in charge.
The one thing they agreed
on, "Don't call in CDC."
(Saad laughs)
And so this is a problem
because we made WHO weaker
than it needed to be.
Then what do we do?
We give them a Board of Directors
of 193 ministers of health.
And there's no one that would
accept a job at a company
in the United States with a
Board of Directors of 193,
195 people.
And third, we join the course every year,
telling them to reduce their budget.
And that's where the Dolly
Parton quote comes in,
that, I said, we will finally learn
how much it costs to look this cheap.
And I think 2014 in Africa
with Ebola, we got our answer.
And we need to support WHO
so it has the same resources
and abilities, and technology
that the world needs to have,
a strong public health institution.
- Absolutely. Right.
And I think that as we
will look back on 2020,
we will finally account
for the consequences
of the US pulling out, and
being antagonistic toward WHO.
So you refer to COVAX,
or you alluded to COVAX,
that the system that was
created to provide vaccines,
there were no takers.
Initially they didn't have the money,
and then they didn't have the backing
from big countries like the US
who were working against the
interest of COVAX and WHO.
And so that gap created the
gap in interest and funding,
and effort, created such vulnerabilities.
And I would submit that we
are still paying the price
in terms of increased risk
of variance, et cetera.
So one of my colleague is asking,
that there are a lot of
stories of smallpox eradication
that includes the stories
from specific countries.
Somalia, for example, comes up a few times
as one of the last places with smallpox,
and India was part of the story of polio,
and Pakistan and Afghanistan,
and Nigeria, et cetera.
So what are the implications
of global health governance
of outbreaks and relationships
between countries
and international bodies?
Because yes, even if
you set aside, WHO Afro,
there was a delicate
dance with the countries,
and you had firsthand experience
dealing with countries
both from within, based
on your deployments,
but in your WHO and CDC roles as well.
- Well, the interesting
thing was that we were able
to do this with the Soviet
Union during the Cold War.
And so in India, I actually
supervised some people
from the Soviet Union who in
turn supervised Americans.
Now, you can't imagine that happening
in any other structure at
that time during the Cold War.
But with health, we can have objectives
that are much more important
than the political differences.
And so that's what WHO
has to keep emphasizing,
what we have to keep emphasizing,
that we're willing to work with anybody
in order to improve health.
- Yeah. And so a as we wind down,
and we had sort of last
five minutes of our time,
I would love for you to talk about
what advice would you share
with early career investigators,
young professionals, aspiring
public health professionals,
et cetera, because a lot of
them are part of our audience
as students and early
stage faculty, and others.
And I will share a personal anecdote,
when I became the Bill Foe
professor in my previous job,
it was almost funny as if
someone had given a form letter
to people who wrote to me to congratulate,
and there was one sentence
that was very consistent,
surprisingly consistent,
and it was Bill Foege is
my public health hero.
And after the first two, three emails,
and these were people
I respected, et cetera.
But so from that perspective,
of someone who has made
contributions to public health,
who has been witnessed
to a lot of successes,
but also a lot of shortcomings
of the public health system
in the US and globally,
what advice would you give
to aspiring and early stage
public health professionals
and scientists?
- It's a question I like
to deal with actually.
And first of all, be very
careful about a life plan.
'Cause you can have no
idea what opportunities
are going to be presented to you,
you have no idea what the new problems
are gonna be two years from now.
So be careful about
solidifying a life plan.
Number two, I tell the students
that if you go into global health,
you're not likely to get rich,
but you're also not likely to get thanked.
(Saad laughs)
But if you can get
beyond those two things,
it's re very rewarding.
And I tell them the
story of Pearl Kendrick,
who worked for the Michigan
health department in the 1930s.
And she developed pertussis
vaccine with another woman
working in the Health Department.
And when she died in 1980,
the Dean of the School of Public Health
at the University of
Michigan, Bill Remington,
gave a eulogy.
And he said, "There are
hundreds of thousands of people
who are alive because of Pearl Kendrick."
And he paused, and then he
asked, "Could you name one?"
He said, "I can't either."
And that's why she was
never adequately thanked.
But he said, "She was
secure in the knowledge
of what she was doing."
And so I tell students,
you won't get rich,
you won't be thanked, but be secure
in the knowledge of what you are doing.
And then I suggest to them that
in any program they go into,
or any particular project
that they go into,
to have three things in mind.
Number one, the science.
And Huxley defined science as simply,
common sense at its best.
So lots of people get afraid
of science these days,
and you could see what's
happening in this country
with coronavirus, people that
don't believe the sciences,
but they all think they have common sense.
And so if you define science
as common sense at its best,
it makes it palatable.
But number two, Will Duran said,
"Add to the science
art, because," he said,
"Then you have creative
common sense at its best."
And he uses as his example
in Motap from Egypt,
who was a physician and an artist,
he designed the step pyramid
and then he had it built.
So he says, "Adding art to your science
gives you that creativity."
But there's a third thing, and that is,
to add a moral compass.
And Roger Bacon is the example
I use from 700 years ago,
when the Pope asked him
for a summary of science.
And bacon worked a long
time on that summary.
And then decided it's too long.
And so he did a summary of
the summary, and finally,
he did a summary of the
summary of the summary,
that went to the Pope.
Now I've not looked at this for decades,
but there were three things
that came to mind for me.
Number one, he was absolutely
enthusiastic about science.
He predicted planes, submarines and cars.
He predicted telescopes,
this is 700 years ago.
So he was very excited about it.
And number two, what I recall is that,
after talking about the
possibilities of science,
he said, "But science
has no moral compass."
So you have to create
scientists with a moral compass.
And the third thing, and
this is what makes me think
the Pope never actually read it.
He said, the church is
doing nothing to help them
to provide a moral compass.
So here we are still today,
get the science right, add art,
get a moral compass, and put
those three things together,
and now you have moral, creative,
common sense at its best.
That's the shortest description I can make
of what it should be like
to go into global health.
- Thank you, really appreciate that.
Thank you for joining us today.
Thanks for all your passion,
wisdom and moral leadership
in global health for many decades.
Thank you to the audience
who joined us today.
We are hoping to have our fall season
for the conversation series
in-person, or at least hybrid.
So stay tuned, we have a lot
of exciting guests lined up,
and look forward to seeing you there.
Even if we do it in-person,
those of you who join
from around the country
and from various parts of the world,
you should be able to
follow us online as well
even at that time.
So thank you everyone,
and especially Dr. Foege.
- Thank you Saad.